Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Tutti i grandi passaggi della Storia
sono partiti da un'idea folle,
dirompente, tabù.
Tutti i grandi progressi sociali,
scientifici, tecnologici
sono partiti dall'immaginare l'impossibile
prima ancora di capire esattamente
come ci saremmo arrivati.
Dietro queste idee innovative
ci sono sempre stati degli individui
capaci di portare, dietro di loro,
e di riunire centinaia, migliaia,
milioni di voci e di forze
chiamate in causa
e convinte che cambiare si può.
Dietro ognuna di queste grandi idee
c'è sempre stato un uomo o una donna
che ha iniziato a nuotare controcorrente.
L'importante è partire,
osare, rischiare, provarci.
Gli imprenditori sociali
sono questo, per noi.
Sono uomini e donne
che scoprono le cause profonde
di un problema sociale, o ambientale,
e trovano delle soluzioni
creative per risolverli.
In fondo, lo spirito
imprenditoriale è questo:
intraprendenza, creatività,
leadership e coraggio.
Tipicamente, gli imprenditori sociali
iniziano a trovare, ad avere dietro di se
alcuni seguaci, che iniziano a seguirli,
forse all'inizio per migliorare
le proprie condizioni personali,
o quelle della propria famiglia.
Ma capendo che, in un secondo momento,
si potrebbe migliorare le condizioni
di molti, e magari poi di tutti.
Diversi studi dimostrano
che quando il 16% di una popolazione
inizia a cambiare
un comportamento sociale,
da lì in poi, in brevissimo tempo,
tutti gli altri seguono
con una crescita esponenziale.
Questo succede
per i comportamenti sociali umani:
ad esempio, la diffusione
dei telefonini cellulari.
Inizialmente un gruppo
ristretto di persone;
poi un gruppo di precursori;
e infine, in brevissimo tempo
ce l'avevamo tutti in tasca.
Ma non solo:
succede anche in situazioni sociali
non umane, di altre specie!
Quando il 16% di uno stormo, per esempio,
inizia a cambiare direzione,
ecco che seguono tutti gli uccelli.
Quando il 16% dei pesci
cambia direzione di nuoto,
ecco che segue tutto il banco.
In statistica, questo viene
rappresentato in questo modo:
un gruppo ristretto di innovatori
che insieme ai precursori fanno il 16%
e da lì, nello stesso tempo
in cui questo cambiamento è successo,
riusciamo ad ottenere
un cambiamento massivo,
fino a quando poi
arrivano anche i ritardatari.
Ashoka, l'organizzazione globale
che rappresento in Italia,
da 35 anni è alla ricerca
di questi innovatori sociali.
Di questi imprenditori sociali,
di questi pesciolini che iniziano
a nuotare controcorrente.
Quello che facciamo è sceglierli
per la loro creatività,
il loro spirito imprenditoriale,
la loro fibra etica,
il loro impatto sociale
e la loro innovazione.
Li sosteniamo economicamente,
ma soprattutto circondandoli
da una rete di esperti,
di consulenze e di alleati
che possa portare
questi cambi di paradigma
che hanno trovato
a far diventare universali.
Per noi, il modo migliore per risolvere
tutti i problemi sociali del mondo
non è quello di implementare
dei programmi dall'alto,
ma di andare a trovare
chi ha già scovato delle soluzioni,
per quanto imperfette
o applicabili solo localmente,
ma ad aiutare queste persone
a portare questa innovazione a diventare
un cambio di paradigma universale.
Ashoka opera da 35 anni,
in 85 Paesi al mondo, in 15 Paesi Europei,
ma è arrivata in Italia
solo l'anno scorso.
In tanti mi chiedevano:
perché siete arrivati così tardi?
Non ho tutte le risposte,
ma una possibile interpretazione
è che il nostro Paese,
dalla fine della Seconda Guerra Mondiale
fino alla crisi petrolifera
degli anni '70,
è riuscito veramente
a compiere un miracolo
attraverso il lavoro, l'intraprendenza,
la creatività di uomini e donne,
che, con la loro innovazione
e con la loro forza,
hanno portato un Paese distrutto
dalla guerra - e, in larga parte, povero -
a diventare una delle potenze economiche
più grandi del mondo.
Ma non solo:
abbiamo creato un welfare di stato
tra i più solidi al mondo,
abbiamo rinnovato
nell'arte, nella medicina,
nell'architettura,
in quasi tutte le discipline.
Poi, paradossalmente,
dagli anni '70 in poi,
più diventavamo un popolo
istruito e colto,
meno ci siamo messi a rinnovare.
Siamo diventati esperti
di analisi dei problemi,
con pochissima attenzione alla critica
e al cambiamento.
Quali sono i risultati?
Questi sono dati di quest'anno
sullo spirito imprenditoriale
in 200 paesi al mondo.
Siamo terzultimi, dopo la Bulgaria
- un Paese ex comunista -
e il Suriname, che è coperto
all'80% da foresta.
Spirito imprenditoriale e capacità
di cambiamento vanno a braccetto:
per questo, per noi, la scuola,
i genitori, gli educatori
devono insegnarci a provare, a sbagliare,
a imparare dai nostri sbagli.
A capire se si tratta
di errore strategico, metodologico
o semplicemente di sfortuna.
A riprovare fino a quando riusciamo
ad ottenere un risultato.
E questo vale per un impresa sociale,
per un'impresa economica,
o per qualsiasi progetto di cambiamento
che una persona possa avere.
In un mondo fordista,
basato sulla ripetizione,
poteva anche avere un senso
un sistema educativo universale,
standard, adatto a tutti.
Ma nella società contemporanea,
in continuo cambiamento,
c'è bisogno di sperimentazione,
d'innovazione.
C'è bisogno non di omogeneità
ma di creatività,
non di nozione ma di opinione.
Io ho avuto la fortuna di studiare
in una scuola pubblica, in Italia,
fino a 17 anni, in una classe come questa
- questa è una foto scattata 3 giorni fa,
ma a parte quel minuscolo computer
credo che evochi a tutti
un ricordo della scuola
che abbiamo fatto in questo Paese.
Poi, a 17 anni, ho avuto
la fortuna ancora maggiore
di essere selezionato
con una borsa di studio
per finire gli studi in Canada.
Ero appassionato di filosofia,
e ho deciso di continuare
a studiarla anche là.
Ma non avevo mai letto
un testo originale.
Da noi la filosofia
era interpretata e spiegata
attraverso il libro di testo,
poi a sua volta interpretata
e spiegata dal professore.
Più la si ripeteva uguale,
più alto era il voto.
Arrivato in Canada,
il professore, Andrew,
distribuisce a tutti una copia
del Simposio di Platone.
E dice: avete una settimana per leggerlo,
poi settimana prossima ne parliamo.
E così leggo questo libro,
in realtà molto
più interessante e scabroso
di come ce lo definiva il libro di testo,
e, tornato a scuola, Andrew mi chiede:
"Alessandro, tu che hai
studiato già filosofia,
dimmi un po': cosa ne pensi?
Ti ha convinto l'interpretazione
di Platone della morale?"
E io: "Oddio, criticare Platone?
Non mi permetterei mai!"
Per fortuna, però, col tempo
ho imparato che tutto era criticabile,
perché tutto si può cambiare.
In realtà la buona notizia
è che non c'è mai stato
nessun momento più opportuno
per nessuno di noi,
nella storia dell'uomo,
per poter cambiare tutte le cose
e nel minor tempo possibile.
E anche se forse pensiamo
di essere continuamente minacciati
da attacchi terroristici, da guerre
di religione, da catastrofi climatiche,
in realtà non c'è mai stato un momento
in cui sono stati meglio
come homo sapiens.
Questi ad esempio sono alcuni dati
sui morti per le guerre,
nella Storia, dagli anni '40 ad oggi.
Come vedete, il numero è in continuo calo,
e guardate che la popolazione del mondo,
nel frattempo, è quasi raddoppiata.
La speranza di vita sta aumentando
dovunque, nel pianeta.
La mortalità infantile
sta diminuendo dappertutto.
Abbiamo sconfitto
la maggior parte delle malattie
che per secoli e secoli e millenni
l'uomo ha dovuto combattere.
Certo, ci sono tanti problemi sociali
ancora da risolvere,
e i problemi ambientali sono ancora più
importanti e più difficili da risolvere;
ma siamo connessi e interconnessi
e più che mai, oggi,
la globalizzazione e la tecnologia
ci permettono di trovare una soluzione
in un angolo del Pianeta
e di portarla - ovviamente
adattandola culturalmente -
in un altro angolo del Pianeta.
Abbiamo quindi la possibilità
di risolvere tutti i problemi sociali,
se lo vogliamo.
Questo è il compito di Ashoka:
selezionare l'innovazione,
accompagnare gli imprenditori sociali,
quei pesciolini che nuotano
controcorrente,
per far sì che la loro innovazione
possa diventare un movimento
che acceleri il cambiamento
sociale nel tempo.
Un altro compito importante
è quello di mettere insieme
gli innovatori sociali
che operano nello stesso campo,
sebbene in posti diversi
e con metodi diversi.
Ad esempio, tutti gli imprenditori sociali
che lavorano con i bambini
da zero a dieci anni
ci dicono che la cosa
più importante in assoluto
è insegnare loro l'empatia,
cioè sapersi mettere emotivamente
nei panni degli altri.
Non la matematica, non l'italiano,
ma l'empatia.
Chi lavora con gli adolescenti
ci dice che la cosa
più importante da insegnare loro
è quella di metterli nelle condizioni
di vedersi come attori del cambiamento,
nella loro classe, nel loro quartiere,
nella loro scuola,
nella loro città e nel mondo intero.
Vi possono sembrare dei concetti
forse eccessivamente astratti, strambi:
però provate a pensare
come poteva essere, 300 anni fa, dire:
tutti i bambini devono imparare
a leggere e a scrivere,
non solo i figli dei nobili!
Oppure, 150 anni fa, dire:
anche le donne devono poter votare.
Non solo: devono poter diventare
Presidenti e Ministri a loro volta.
O anche solo 30 anni fa, a dire:
due uomini e due donne che si amano
devono potersi sposare.
E invece, guardate cos'è successo:
questi sono alcuni dati sulla diffusione
dell'alfabetizzazione nel mondo.
L'analfabetismo, fino al 1600,
era condizione praticamente universale.
Nel 1700 è passato ad essere
la condizione dei poveri,
comunque la stragrande
maggioranza della popolazione.
Poi, col diffondersi del protestantesimo
- e quindi la necessità, da parte anche
dell'uomo comune, di leggere la Bibbia -
inizia ad emergere un nuovo paradigma
che per noi è stato annunciato
nel 1720 da William Hanley, che dice:
"Tutti, non solo i figli dei ricchi,
devono imparare a leggere e a scrivere."
Questa diventa prima una battaglia
all'interno della Chiesa,
poi all'interno dello Stato,
del Regno Unito dove operava Hanley.
E, a poco a poco, da lì
nel 1820 il 20% della popolazione
sa leggere e scrivere,
che poi diventa 40, 50, 70,
fino ad arrivare, al giorno d'oggi,
all'85% della popolazione globale.
In Inghilterra, il Paese in cui viveva,
si è arrivati al 100% nel 1920.
Dall'enunciare il nuovo paradigma
alla sua universalizzazione in Inghilterra
sono passati 200 anni,
circa 8 generazioni.
Vorrei presentarvi ora un altro caso:
questa persona si chiama Kate Shepherd.
Kate Shepherd, nel 1890,
nell'oscura e remota colonia britannica
chiamata Nuova Zelanda,
dice una cosa che non era
mai stata detta prima:
tutte le differenze di razza,
di religione, di classe
ma anche di sesso sono sbagliate,
e quindi devono essere combattute.
Ma Kate non era soltanto
una brava oratrice:
era soprattutto una brava organizzatrice!
Riesce a coinvolgere
dietro di se migliaia di donne
che appoggiano la sua battaglia
per i diritti politici delle donne,
ma non solo: riesce ad attirare
dietro di se anche degli uomini,
con cui, nel 1893, riesce
ad ottenere lo storico risultato
di far votare le donne
nella Nuova Zelanda.
Da lì inizia un processo
che nel corso dei decenni
vede sempre più paesi approvare
il suffragio universale,
maschile e femminile.
Come vedete, quando si arriva
negli anni '30 e '40 circa al 16%,
da lì in poi vediamo un'impennata.
E molto velocemente si arriva
agli anni '70 - '80
in cui praticamente tutti i Paesi
del mondo davano la possibilità
- quando ci sono le elezioni,
e poi vere o finte è un altro discorso -
anche alle donne di votare.
Al giorno d'oggi tutti i paesi al mondo,
tranne Città del Vaticano e Brunei,
concedono questo diritto.
Possiamo quindi vedere come un paradigma
- possiamo pensare a una bambina,
nata nel 1890 in un mondo
in cui nessuna donna può votare,
che muore a 90 anni, nel 1980,
in un mondo in cui praticamente
tutte le donne possono votare.
Il tempo si è ristretto ancora di più:
nel corso della vita di una persona,
vediamo l'emergere di un paradigma
e la sua universalizzazione.
Ma vediamo i giorni nostri:
questi sono due ragazzi,
negli anni '70 in Minnesota
- Jack Becker, e Michael McConnell -
che decidono di volersi sposare.
Fanno una cosa che non era
mai stata fatta prima:
vanno all'anagrafe e chiedono
di potersi sposare civilmente.
Ovviamente la loro richiesta
viene derisa e poi bocciata,
ma da lì parte un nuovo paradigma:
i diritti delle persone omosessuali
non sono solo diritti individuali,
ma diritti di coppia.
Da lì, 15 anni dopo, nel 1989,
la Danimarca approva
le prime unioni civili;
nel 2001 l'Olanda approva
il primo matrimonio ugualitario
fino ad arrivare agli ultimi 15 anni
in cui praticamente dappertutto,
nel mondo Occidentale e in America Latina,
qualche sorta di unione tra persone
dello stesso sesso è stata approvata.
Siamo nel mezzo di questa
impennata del 16%.
E mentre prima erano secoli,
poi decenni, ora si tratta di anni.
E abbiamo così una persona come me,
che nasce nel 1982 in un mondo in cui
nessun omosessuale si poteva sposare;
quando finisco le elementari parte l'idea
di unione civile in Danimarca;
quando finisco le superiori in Olanda
una coppia si può sposare;
a 29 anni posso sposarmi io,
con mio marito, in Argentina;
e a 34 anni, finalmente, anche in Italia
il mio matrimonio viene riconosciuto.
(Applausi)
Se vi chiedete dove sono,
adesso, Jack e Michael,
stanno ancora insieme
e finalmente sono sposati.
Quindi il mio lavoro è proprio questo:
riuscire, in Italia,
a scovare quei pesciolini
che nuotano controcorrente
e che possono portarci
a un cambiamento sociale,
a un cambio di paradigma, e ad aiutarli
ad accelerare questo cambio di paradigma.
Gli imprenditori sociali sono merce rara:
ce n'è circa uno ogni dieci
milioni d'abitanti.
Quindi, in Italia, ho il compito
di trovarne circa sei all'anno.
Questi sono i primi sei che ho trovato,
uomini e donne eccezionali
che ci hanno veramente fatto capire
dei cambi di paradigma
che potrebbero diventare universali.
C'è chi ci insegna che la lotta alla mafia
non è soltanto una scelta etica,
ma una possibilità di sviluppo
economico e psicologico
di alcune tra le popolazioni
più povere d'Europa.
Chi ci insegna che la maternità,
il congedo di maternità
e anche di paternità,
è un'occasione per imparare,
un'occasione utile a noi
ma anche alla società intera
e ai datori di lavoro.
O chi ci insegna che la
riabilitazione da ictus infantile
può essere un gioco,
non necessariamente ospedalizzata.
Da dove si parte, da qua?
Ovviamente il mondo non si può
cambiare con questi sei,
o con le tre, quattro persone
che lavorano con me.
Occorre che tutti facciano la loro parte.
"Tutti possono essere
attori del cambiamento"
vuol dire che ognuno può essere
attore del cambiamento.
Se siete ad esempio dei genitori,
battetevi perché nelle vostre scuole
inizino a insegnarsi
queste nuove competenze,
o provate a insegnarle voi
direttamente a casa.
Se siete degli studenti,
battetevi non solo
per riportare la scuola
come era trent'anni fa, qua,
ma per capire cosa c'è di nuovo
e cosa potrebbe cambiare veramente
la vostra vita come cittadini,
non solo come studenti.
Se siete dei media,
provate a parlare anche
di storie positive di cambiamento,
non solo di tragedie.
Se siete delle aziende,
non vedetevi soltanto
come macchine di produzione,
ma come co-creatori del cambiamento.
Se percepite un problema sociale,
non aspettate che sia qualcun'altro
a fare il primo passo,
ma fatelo voi!
Se credete che il cambiamento
sia possibile, non aspettate domani:
il momento giusto è oggi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)